well guys with grown-ups tubing out in
theaters right now and red - coming out
soon we seem to be in a very unnecessary
sequels face read two stars Bruce Willis
John Malkovich mary-louise Parker
Anthony Hopkins Catherine zeta-jones I
mean this movie has a humongous cast of
extremely good actors a lot of these
actors have been in great movies before
the first red
I didn't mind actually I thought it
wasn't that terrible it was an OK action
film it wasn't a great movie but it
wasn't that bad of a time either I had
an enjoyable time watching it I only
watched it once never really felt that I
need to watch it again but it certainly
didn't really warrant a sequel in my
mind in this film we have these older
retired DC Comics believe it or not
characters and the whole thing this
movie really is old people can still
kick butt and I don't mind that I
enjoyed the Expendables quite a bit I
really like the newer rocky film I like
films where you can show that an older
dude can still be rugged and awesome
like grant arena with Clint Eastwood and
in this movie there's this big plot
involving this chemical that could
possibly blow up large chunks of the
earth who's gonna get their hands on it
gotta protect it from the right people
at the same time there's an assassin
after Bruce Willis and company and his
girl mary-louise parker kind of wants to
be more in on the action she wants to
get in on the heist and the explosions
and the shootouts and everything and
Helen Mirren is back in this film at
first she has a smaller rolled and you
would think she had but it gets more
expansive as the film continues there's
a whole bunch of other celebrity cameos
that I'm not gonna spoil for you but to
be honest read - from the beginning felt
very unnecessary and as I watched the
film it became even more increasingly
unnecessary read - is a movie that felt
more like an extensive Looney Toons
episode starring Bruce Willis then a fun
action comedy there was one great scene
very early on in this movie where Bruce
Willis had to take out a whole bunch of
guards and it was pretty cool even
though a lot of it was definitely a
stunt double I really like the way they
handled that scene but the rest of the
movie really feels like an over
extensive cartoon gag filled with funny
jokes and lots of explosions one of
those movies where every other line has
to be like a pun or a slapstick
reference of some kind see one of the
things that really annoyed me about this
movie was mary-louise Parker's character
she constantly is literally begging
Bruce Willis to be part of the action
she just wants to have a gun she wants
to be out there doing everything he's
doing she wants the respect that he gets
and whenever he gives her that
opportunity whenever he says here do
this do
guard here take this weapon or whatever
she acts like a cartoon character she
doesn't even attempt to try to actually
do what she wants to do so bad she
always messes it up left and right and
it's like it was just really stupid
Anthony Hopkins shows up and he is
awesome I love Anthony Hopkins and
honestly I like most of the actors in
this movie it's a really great cast
I've liked almost every one of these
actors and projects before Anthony
Hopkins in the movie shows up he's very
interesting he's a funny comical guy
he's an interesting edge to his
character and he was pretty good in the
movie very rarely will you ever say
Anthony Hopkins yeah he kind of ruined
that movie I mean for goodness sake
she's Hannibal Lecter he's awesome red
to just really came up as a movie that
was trying to be too many different
things where it tried to be an
interesting action film it just wasn't
directed with enough flair to be that it
didn't look good enough it wasn't
horribly filmed but there was just
nothing terribly interesting about the
way this movie was made the script and
the dialogue makes no sense characters
jump from location to location to
location with barely any transition
whatsoever and it just seems so messed
up and convoluted read to is a movie
that could have been a lot of fun has
some good performances in there has some
funny moments has some okay action
scenes and it's not a movie that you sit
there and you hate yourself watching if
it came on TV you could probably have it
on the background and not feel like
killing yourself but for the most part
this is just a really stupid movie so
I'm gonna give red to a c-minus so when
the movie comes out guys I'd be
interested in knowing what you thought
of it what do you think of the first
film that's what I'd like to know
as always guys thanks for watching and
if you like my glasses you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes